[Music]  was there any chemistry between you and  normani you know what I love that girl  she is just so beautiful inside and out  when she walks in the room whole room  lights up notice how he avoided the  question is there any chemistry but you  know what I think she is a beautiful  lady and if she asked me out on a date I  would sure enough go okay so why don't  you just ask her out on a date well yeah  that's that's the real thing if I ask  her out on normani will you go on a date  with me  Bonner I love this is this real can this  really happen I don't know we'll see  what she says hopefully she's watching  normanni it would be an honor to go on a  date with you moon I love this my heart  is fluttering right now real magic is  happening who are you rooting for now  who do you want to see win oh I want to  see her win she's definitely my favorite  now she had me be a part of her numbers  so I'm rooting for you girl  [Music]  you